avatar The Way of the water even if it
is a massive Commercial Success it could
it could still be a massive commercial
failure welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and movie channel
[Music]
the humans are returning they're hunting
us so James Cameron has been talking
about the way of water which is about to
be released in cinemas and he made a bit
of a throwaway comment that this movie
is going to have to make at least two
billion dollars just to break even
now that is a big number he was asked in
the interview well how much did it cost
to make avatar The Way of the water and
he just sort of skirted around it and
went a crapload of money and actually
swore a little bit
so
this film might have actually all in
cost nearly 2 billion quid to make that
is what we can infer from what James
Cameron has said
so first of all let's think about how on
Earth does it cost that much to make
before comparing to other movies it been
released recently and considering
whether it's got any chance of ever
actually making that money back
well initially in back in 2017 the
budget for the movie was 270 million
but it was supposed to be on the screens
two years ago
well obviously it's had a crapload of
over runs and a little pandemic there in
the middle which obviously hasn't helped
things
but also James Cameron has got a bit of
a reputation for actually going above
and beyond for his movies
think about Titanic now he could have
with sets and you know special effects
and things made that movie for a
significantly less money but instead he
decided to build a two-thirds scale
replica model of the Titanic snap it in
half and sink it now he didn't
necessarily need to do that but he did
because it was what was right for the
movie and I feel James Cameron might
have done the same here and the studios
will back him up because what we have to
remember is the first Avatar movie with
a budget that was reasonably modest took
nearly 3 billion in the box office now
that does include its current re-release
which has made around 100 million in the
box office worldwide
so
Avatar way of water making 3 billion
again piece of piss surely
well since covid
these cinematic world is completely
different
let's look at the most successful movie
of this year
top gun Maverick
now films even Marvel movies have
struggled to make a billion dollars but
top gun Maverick made 1.5 billion nearly
now that really has been the biggest
film of the Year by a long stretch no
other film is coming from close
so avatar The Way of the water is going
to have to exceed that in the winter
months remember as well this isn't the
big summer blockbuster movie this has
been released over Christmas where
notoriously people don't go to the
cinema as much
it's also obviously been released
post-covered
I think this movie will be lucky to make
the 1.5 billion in worldwide box office
Top Gun did so that means it is set to
potentially lose
500 million dollars at the worldwide box
office now the list of movies that have
lost 100 million dollars when you adjust
for inflation it's actually quite long
there's a couple of Transformers movies
in there there's a Jupiter Ascending
we're Channing Tatum who I'm going to
come back to in a minute and to run as
the list goes on and on the postman with
Kevin Costner Water World the first
movie ever to cost 100 million dollars
to make actually if you're in just for
inflation broke even now the list of
movies that have lost 200 million
dollars is a little bit shorter now the
two main ones on that list are Cutthroat
Island with Jeannie Davis
[Music]
which depending on how you do the math
lost something between 150 or 200
million dollars
and Disney's John Carpenter now John
Carpenter for me he's actually not a bad
movie to be honest neither was Cutthroat
Island I thought they were advertised
poorly and so people didn't really know
what they're going to watch and they
just maybe release at the wrong time
John Carpenter for me just had the wrong
cast they put the wrong person in the
lead if they'd have got Channing Tatum
who I mentioned earlier see I've put the
link these things together if they'd put
Channing Tatum into the main part he was
desperate to do it according to reports
then I actually think the movie would
have done well
but they didn't they put that guy in
whose name I can't even remember and the
film bombed James Cameron's Avatar
sequel could be set even if it is a
massive Commercial Success to equal the
biggest movie so far of the year is set
to Eclipse those losses massively
but do we care if it's a great movie and
it's a massive success and it makes 1.5
billion dollars in the box office do we
care if it doesn't quite make enough
money well yeah
if you want to see a third one or a
fourth one or a fifth one of God knows
how many other Avatar movies he's
playing to make now if you want to see
those extra sequels this film has to
make money now James Cameron in the
interview actually said that this is
possibly the worst business decision
ever and he he must know this he must
know that by talking about it to be fair
that this is a this is potentially a
problem
when have you ever heard directors
talking about how much money the movie
needs to make to break even before the
film comes out
and if the film does lose 500 million
dollars in the box office there isn't
the DVD sales to follow it to try and
make some more of that money back now
back in the day when there were DVD
sales a lot of filmmakers weren't that
bothered if the film didn't do great to
the box office because they knew it
would generally do well in the DVD sales
every Kevin Smith movie ever it kept
being allowed to make movies because his
DVD sales always at least eclipsed the
box office receipts so
he always made money there are no DVD
sales anymore to make money it is going
just to go to streaming which means the
streaming service has to pay for it and
they will not pay hundreds of millions
of dollars for Avatar or it will not
make hundreds of millions of dollars for
the producers
so
really everything lies on the box office
receipts
and it would be a miracle if they made
their money back and then what will be
the result of that
we probably won't get to see Avatar
three or four or five or six or seven or
eight or however many plan to make I
mean could you imagine if this is just a
moderate success and only takes a
billion dollars at the box office
this could be the first film to lose a
billion dollars at box office and now
that would be a complete disaster but
guys get in the comments tell me what
you think is Avatar the way of water for
one a movie you're desperately excited
for
oh is it a film here not really bothered
like me to be honest I'm not really fast
and welcome to the beautiful North Wales
I've got a caravan up here by the way so
every so often I'm going to be doing
these little walkie videos and isn't it
a lovely sunny day yay going North Wales
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you enjoy the content and you want to
support the channel even further
consider hitting the join button and
becoming a fully fledged side Trekker as
always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]